We're here with Kei Nishikori.
He just did a great appearance at Swetka's Tennis Shop in Mountain View, California.
Kei, thank you very much for today.
Yes, thank you.
And we're just gonna ask you a couple of questions.
Rock or hip-hop?
Hip-hop.
Your favorite song to karaoke to?
Let me think, it's gonna be Japanese for sure.
Okay.
Coffee or tea?
Tea.
Coke or Diet Coke?
Coke.
Vanilla or chocolate?
Vanilla.
I can't eat chocolate.
Chopsticks, fork or knife?
Chopsticks, for sure.
Favorite type of sushi?
Tuna, fatty tuna.
Favorite Cup-o-noodle flavor?
Pork.
Favorite baseball team?
I don't know...
Yeah, Giants.
Okay.
How about favorite baseball player?
It could be Ichiro.
Good answer, good answer.
Favorite movie?
Favorite movie, "Taxi," it's a French movie.
"Taxi."
Favorite actress?
Cameron Diaz.
Blond or brunettes?
Cameron Diaz is blond.
Yeah, blond.
The favorite thing about your Wilson Tour BLX racket?
Power and control.
Good, well, thank you very much, Kei.
We appreciate it.
Let's have a round of applause for Kei.